mapping the planet tracking space debris
delivering breaking news
cases like these and so many more have
been built atop Cloud run our platform
for serverless containers in Google
Cloud so stick around to learn how we're
moving serverless forward with Cloud run
at its Inception Cloud run was ideal for
web services USU HTTP requests the
service does something and returns a
response for workloads like these Cloud
run was great in that it automatically
scaled the web service to meet traffic
demands of any size and it still is
but industries of all kinds wanted that
same serverless experience write code
let the platform scale and do the rest
for all workloads not just web serving
examples of these include regularly
scheduled jobs and Scripts
and these jobs and scripts could range
from orchestrating internal workflows to
doing lightweight data Transformations
they might even run on a schedule or
they might run when an event happens and
they exit when they're done now
technically this was possible with
services in Cloud run your web service
could respond to an HTTP request for
example by running the work typically
done by the job
but what if the job runs longer than a
typical timeout for web services you'd
need to do things like slice the job
into smaller pieces and workarounds like
these require code changes making it
harder to adopt a serverless platform
that's why we're building atop this
model and moving serverless forward in
Cloud run
with a couple of new features we now can
support workloads like data
Transformations database migrations even
workloads that need Network file system
access
let's dive in two features in Cloud run
expand our serverless support for more
workload types the first is cloud run
jobs
this allows you to bring containers with
long run to completion jobs no need to
hack around HTTP requests and rewrite
code
the second is a second generation of our
Cloud run execution environment
this environment provides faster CPU and
network performance to intensive
workloads that need it and lets you
mount Network file systems
it even brings full compatibility with
all Linux features let's dig a bit
deeper into each with Cloud run jobs
imagine you have old Legacy scripts that
do batch processing
with Cloud run jobs you don't need
workarounds like wrapping it with a web
server instead as long as you can
containerize them you can make them
serverless with Cloud run jobs these
scripts can spin up automatically on the
schedule run tasks in parallel and spin
down upon completion
this serverless experience gives you
more time to focus on the business with
the Simplicity of provisioning via a
single gcloud command now let's dig into
the second generation execution
environment
right off the bat this environment
provides faster CPU and network
performance for CPU intensive workloads
or workload sensitive to packet loss but
in addition to this it also supports all
kernel level Linux features syscalls c
groups namespaces you name it
this increases the number of migration
targets of Legacy software that used to
not be able to run in Cloud run due to
some missing Linux support
another important Point mounting file
systems whether or not they are in
Google cloud is possible in the second
generation environment
this means that workloads can use NFS
SMB sifs or fuse to access data they
might need to process
even if it's outside of Google Cloud
with this support workloads won't need a
rewrite at the storage layer taking
advantage of all the benefits of the
second generation execution environment
is baked into a simple argument you
provide when deploying to Cloud run with
these two features we're enabling more
kinds of workloads to do amazing things
in Cloud run moving serverless forward
to try out Cloud run jobs or the new
Cloud run second generation environment
check out the documentation in the
description below and if you want to be
notified of what the cloud run team
comes up with next be sure to like And
subscribe to the Google Cloud Tech
channel for future updates
[Music]
foreign